welcome to the show in American news and
politics there are major groundbreaking
events only every few years so we've had
9/11 we've had the Iraq war passing
Obamacare the first black president an
ignorant reality show hosts being
elected president the National
legalization of gay marriage a president
impeached a few weeks ago it's a sort of
random and incomplete list but the idea
is the truly major news stories aren't
every day the Iran Fiasco that Donald
Trump is building up to including maybe
a war with Iran on the proverbial eve of
his reelection could be one of those
stories as Donald Trump is increasingly
unhinged desperate impeached and trying
to salvage a second term by any means
that he can concoct now as you may know
by now last week Donald Trump ordered an
unauthorized this assassination of the
leader of the Iranian Kurds Kasim
soleimani his behavior is so turbulent
Trump's that is so volatile so manic and
disturbed that the primary allies of the
United States are now clearly and
publicly abandoning Trump on this issue
and by virtue of that abandoning the
United States on this issue we are going
to get into all of this today the Thins
justification for the assassination if
you can even call it a justification the
gaslighting and the lies that are being
told about soleimani including that he
was linked to 9/11 we're going to get to
all of it but I want to sort of start
with the consequences and one of those
is that many of our key allies including
the United Kingdom and Germany and
others are saying stop they're saying no
no no you can't do this we are not with
you if this is what you are going to do
the United Kingdom says that further
conflict is quote in none of our
interests that's not totally true I mean
it might be in Donald Trump's interests
if he thinks it will help him get
reelected and it actually may then it is
sort of in Trump's interest but it's in
very few other people's interests
certainly military contractors seem to
be pleased about what's going
on defense contractors Germany says that
this is potentially a quote dangerous
escalation they don't want it they are
not with Trump and the United States
France has been trying to restore sort
of logic and reason to the Iran nuclear
deal deal after Donald Trump
unilaterally and without any real reason
bailed on the deal and we did this
without consulting France either and
later we will get to Iran is now saying
they are totally out of the Iran nuclear
deal since Trump failed on it anyway so
things not going well there the
Secretary of State for European affairs
Amelie
Demond Shallon told a French radio
station that any unilateral action by
the United States was dangerous we did
this without even telling our European
allies about this now later we'll get
into this maybe tomorrow
it appears that random guests at Donald
Trump's mar-a-lago resort knew more
about what Donald Trump was doing in
Iraq to this Iranian leader than our own
congressional leadership and our own
European allies as former United States
Secretary of Defense Robert McNamara
once said if we had chosen during the
Vietnam era not to do things
unilaterally and without the support of
our allies we never would have gone into
Vietnam in the first place and there are
actually starting to be shades of
history on a few different fronts here
so first is Vietnam the unilateral way
in which Donald Trump seems willing to
approach Iran given his actions so far
with Kasim Soleimani hint at Vietnam
that's one sort of shaded history the
propagandizing that we're already seeing
about it was an imminent threat
Soleimani was connected to 9/11 that is
reminiscent not a Vietnam but of Iraq
and we're going to talk about the the
similarities to the Iraq war propaganda
a little bit later on in the program
today this is all bad and the only thing
that the supporters of Donald Trump's
actions have and there are some on the
right and there are actually some on the
left believe it or not that are
defending the actions of Donald Trump
the only thing that
they have is soleimani was a bad guy
well nobody's denying that Soleimani was
responsible for the deaths of Americans
historically both at that's true
it is not justification here for what
Donald Trump has done it is not
justification for an unhinged unilateral
foreign policy
that immediately gets our longtime
allies to say oh no no no we don't want
anything to do with what's going on
there and it seems that increasingly
Donald Trump is going to have the
support of American Republican senators
and that really may be all he needs to
get what he wants and to do what he
wants to do which again he sees as
something to distract from the fact that
he is an impeached president something
that is extremely embarrassing to him to
the extent that he's able to feel
embarrassment and that's a limited sense
and to the extent that he believes it
will help him to get reelected in 2020
so let's now having sort of gotten to
the consequences first which is our
allies are abandoning us let's get into
some of the sub stories on Trump Iran
this includes the propaganda this
includes information security
justification the legality the threats
of war crimes that Donald Trump is
casually making on Twitter a lot of
Iran's stuff on today's program which by
the way I'm going to get this later is
not at all profitable for me but I don't
want to get put the cart before the
horse we'll get to that a little bit
later let's start with the justification
for the assassination of Kasim soleimani
I want to tell you about a really great
YouTube channel we're partnering with
it's called up flip TV and they've just
recently launched they've have some
excellent content for anybody interested
in business and entrepreneurship check
them out at david pakman.com slash flip
that's FL IP that'll redirect you to
their youtube channel make sure to
subscribe while you're there it is a
YouTube channel that I'd recommend to
anyone in the David Pakman show audience
who owns a business runs a business is
thinking about starting a business or
even if you just like learning new
things about how business works they
interview successful entrepreneurs
business owners
giving them a place to tell their
stories and share strategies so viewers
can benefit from their insight and apply
their wisdom to your own businesses all
of the content is about educating and
inspiring people in each video up flip
TV showcases a different type of startup
it could be a coffee shop or a
landscaping business or a real estate
agency you'll see how the business was
often started from scratch what a
workday looks like how to become and
remain successful in that business and
they don't just interview people they
actually examine each business from
inside out in a really unique way that
distills the valuable lessons that you
can take from their stories I find the
content fascinating they're friends of
the David Pakman show
I would love it if you would go and
support their new YouTube channel and
what they're doing I think you'll very
quickly become a fan like I said get
there by going to david pakman.com slash
flip that's FL IP and make sure to
subscribe to their channel when you're
there